[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de france 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas comenzamos a esta
emisión en francia donde los hallazgos
de un informe han sacudido a la iglesia
católica según la comisión independiente
más de 330.000 menores de edad fueron
abusados sexualmente entre 1950 y 2020
principalmente por parte de miembros del
clero pero también por laicos vinculados
a la institución el papá francisco ha
expresado vergüenza por lo ocurrido en
este país en los últimos 70 años y
mientras tanto las víctimas siguen
clamando por justicia nuestros colegas
de fondos jugados fueron al encuentro de
una de ellas y esta es su historia
es un secreto que guardo durante casi 40
años
tenía 16 años cuando llegué al
monasterio según éstas tres fue violada
por un monje mientras pasaba sus
vacaciones en una abadía era sólo una
adolescente si kim un lúcido me quedé en
una habitación pequeña y desde mi primer
contacto con el monje él cerró la puerta
en sus manos comenzaron a tocar la pared
pérez dijo que estaba plenamente
consciente de lo que estaba haciendo el
libro dice dijo que había sido perdonado
que había sido perdonado por lo que no
estaba haciendo nada malo mezclo eso con
la oración y dijo cosas que en
retrospectiva eran pseudo espirituales
estaba equivocado bueno pero me hizo
pensar que era mi culpa porque yo era
especial séptimo exquisito especial ella
ha sido perseguida por el recuerdo del
abuso pero le contó a su madre hasta que
cumplió 40 años
y
la reacción de mi madre fue yo lo
sospeche debiste haber sufrido en ese
momento pensé que finalmente podía ser
el libre pero al día siguiente ella
cambió de tono le dijo a mis hermanos
que todo había sido una puesta en escena
espiritual tras esto perdí el contacto
con mi madre ella no quería verme y no
la había en diez años hasta que murió
después de años de silencio pérez
testificó ante la comisión independiente
que investigue el abuso sexual en la
iglesia católica una que me creyeron y
pensé que era maravillosos es una pena
que no haya sucedido antes pero es
genial finalmente pude vivir sin sentir
que llevaba una maleta llena de piedras
comienza pérez acaba de terminar sus
estudios de psicoanálisis a los 54 años
ahora libre del peso de su secreto la
disputa de entre parís y londres por los
cruces irregulares de emigrantes se
mantiene y es por eso que francia está
pidiendo negociaciones para lograr un
acuerdo migratorio entre la unión
europea y reino unido un país que tras
él preside ya no hace parte del bloque
de naciones el ministro del interior
francés jon aldea humana denuncia que
reino unido no ha pagado el dinero que
prometió para ayudar a frenar este
fenómeno
estas imágenes están provocando irá al
otro lado del canal a plena luz del día
en esta playa del norte de francia unos
40 inmigrantes kurdos intentan llegar al
reino unido- un helicóptero de la
guardia costera francesa y un grupo de
policías vigilan pero no intervienen al
llegar a las costas británicas este
emigrante parece confirmar que las
autoridades francesas ignoran los hechos
no no dicen nada ya que la policía no es
como los hombres peligrosos del otro
país él no dice que me respeta dijo solo
espera si no puedes esperar ahora venga
el bote grande te llevan hasta allí y
adiós dije muchas gracias
después de prometer recuperar el control
de sus fronteras luego del break sheet
existe una creciente preocupación en
londres por un aumento en el número de
personas que cruzan al reino unido desde
principios de este año más de 17.000
personas lo han hecho y más de 1000 de
ellos han estado allá francia se
defiende en medio de reclamos de una
actitud que no muestra interés en cambio
el ministro del interior francés llega
al dam anna señaló al reino unido
durante una visita al norte de francia
el sábado diciendo que el gobierno
británico aún no ha pagado los 63
millones de euros en un acuerdo para
financiar la vigilancia fronteriza somos
aliados de gran bretaña no somos
vasallos estamos allí para mantener una
frontera es cierto pero debemos hacerlo
con nuestros amigos británicos pido
nuevamente al gobierno británico que
cumpla su promesa francia asumirá la
presidencia de la unión europea el
próximo año y está pidiendo un tratado
entre el bloque y el reino unido sobre
los cruces de inmigrantes
la riqueza en plata del cerro rico de
potosí parece inagotable desde que fue
descubierta en 1545 ésta sigue siendo
explotada en bolivia sin embargo ahora
los riesgos de derrumbes internos
amenazan no solamente la estabilidad de
la montaña sino también la vida de casi
20.000 mineros que van a trabajar ahí
día tras día algunos expertos aseguran
que podría producirse una catástrofe
nuestra corresponsal mary waka nos tiene
la historia
desde hace cinco siglos los mineros
repiten la misma rutina para extraer la
plata del cerro rico de potosí pero la
histórica mina boliviana que en el siglo
17 fue un motor de la economía mundial
se desmorona por dentro y ha perdido la
cúspide existe el miedo pero que
podemos hacer porque necesitamos llevar
el pan del día a nuestra familia yo
tengo cuatro hijos la policía ha
reportado la muerte de al menos 10
mineros en el cerro rico este año para
protegerse miguel hace un rito dedicado
a la imagen del tal como
acostumbran los mineros bolivianos
mejor de los consejos de vida y sigo el
peso de los minerales
y
desde el cielo son visibles los
hundimientos en la cima de la montaña
por no proteger el cerro rico la unesco
puso en 2014 a la ciudad colonial como
patrimonio en peligro el periodista juan
jose toro es un firme defensor del
patrimonio y ha pedido al gobierno
frenar la explotación descontrolada en
la cúspide no se les está diciendo que
se vayan todas las cooperativas sino
solamente las que tienen operaciones
ilegales en la cúspide esos no pasan de
10 por hacer esas denuncias toro ha sido
golpeado por mineros en el año 2020 con
el ex ministro de minería epifanio
mamani luchan para cuidar el cerro rico
mamani dirige una comisión que busca
soluciones porque los hundimientos y
asuman 19 si no se da una solución
inmediata podría ocurrir una catástrofe
donde podrían fallecer muchos operadores
mineros frente a la urgencia mamani ha
propuesto al gobierno y a las
cooperativas mineras que los obreros
sean reubicados en 90 días y los
hundimientos de la cúspide sean
rellenados con materiales especiales en
fotos y salvaguardar el cerro es
proteger el futuro de la ciudad
rusia es el país que puso en órbita el
primer satélite también llevó al primer
perro y el primer hombre y ahora llega a
un nuevo hito la más reciente nave soyuz
en llegar a la estación espacial
internacional transportó a una
tripulación muy particular el director
clips y penco y la actriz julia pérez il
tienen la misión de filmar el desafío el
que será el primer largometraje en
contener escenas filmadas por completo
en el espacio exterior
esta escena podría formar parte de una
película es la actriz rusa yulia perejil
que se prepara para despegar en una
misión a la estación espacial
internacional
viajando con un equipo de la agencia
espacial rusa roscósmos la actriz y su
director atracaron en estación espacial
para filmar escenas de la primera
película que se realizará en el espacio
el equipo de filmación pasará 12 días en
la estación espacial donde el astronauta
francés thomas pesquet es el comandante
ves que no aparecerá en la película pero
los cosmonautas rusos estarán entre los
extras la actriz y directora entrenó
durante 12 semanas antes del lanzamiento
al espacio ordenado hasta el carroccio
store que nos preparamos lo mejor que
pudimos en tan poco tiempo
en cualquier caso fue una experiencia
que no saldría perdedora ni nada por el
estilo estaba muy emocionada feliz
porque muy pocas personas tienen la
oportunidad de ir al espacio de gestión
y prost y colitis fusión la trama y el
presupuesto de la película se han
mantenido en su mayor parte en secreto
sólo se conoce hasta ahora que la
historia se centra en una cirujana que
es enviada a la estación espacial para
salvar cosmonauta 40 minutos de la
película se filmaron en gravedad cero
visibilidad es muy difícil filmar la
gravedad cero en la tierra es casi
imposible reproducirlo con precisión
obras y esquivas words de biblia la
tripulación 2 está lista para superar un
proyecto de hollywood anunciado por tom
cruise y space ex de iu lomos que el año
pasado la primera etapa de la misión ya
está completada superando así a sus
rivales estadounidenses al segundo lugar
en la carrera por filmar una película en
órbita y sumando una larga lista de
novedades para la industria espacial
rusa
gracias por haber seguido una nueva
emisión de corresponsales nos damos cita
la próxima semana siga con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom